bonjour vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de cette ville de syrie nommé
palmyre elle est connue pour son site
antique classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco mais surtout et malheureusement
pour les nombreuses destructions qu'elle
a subie en 2015 sous le régime de dèche
mais pourquoi parler de palmyre puisque
ce n'est ni une femme ni le titre de
l'épisode tout simplement parce que la
vie de zénobie que je vais vous raconter
tout de suite incarne le moment de
l'histoire où pamiers à bria bien
au-delà des frontières et tenta de
s'imposer comme les gars de rome rien
que ça zénobie né à palmyre vers 240
après jésus-christ son nom romain et
julia aurélia zenobia mais elle est
aussi parfois nommée septime ya zenobia
après son mariage sa famille portent des
noms araméen mais il est possible que sa
mère sont originaires d'égypte zénobie
connaît ce pays sa langue et sa culture
et prétend descendre de la lignée de
cléopâtre 7 ainsi que de la reine didon
de carthage l'histoire d'auguste fait
mention d'une déclaration impériale de
269 dans laquelle et nobi qualifie
alexandrie l'egypte comme la cité de ses
ancêtres son père se nomment julie
aurelius des nos bus signe qu'il
possédait la citoyenneté romaine il est
issu d'une famille notables de la ville
et est nommé gouverneur de palmyre en
229 zénobie est décrite comme belle et
intelligente plus encore que cléopâtre
la référence de l'époque l'auteur de
l'histoire d'auguste lui prête de
nombreuses qualités celle d'être chaste
mais aussi des méchas s'est monté à
cheval de savoir diriger et prendre de
décision avec tempérance lorsqu'elle
devient reine elle n'hésite pas à
accompagner ses troupes au combat à pied
ou à cheval cette description dans
l'histoire d'auguste n'est évidemment
pas à prendre au pied de la lettre
puisqu'elle vise un intérêt politique
est rédigée par une personne qui n'a
vraisemblablement jamais côtoyé la vraie
et nobi elle constitue cependant l'une
des principales sources sur cette
période avec l'arrêt ce geste a aidé
ammien marcellin et l'histoire nouvelles
d'eux au team en 251 pas bien devient
une principauté vassal de rome les
dirigeants de la ville sont également
une famille de citoyenneté romaine et
prennent le titre inventer des xxii arc
des palmer est un os des nattes le
prince qui nous attend ace a même été
sénateur romain un petit moment la ville
a une importance économique et
stratégique pour homme puisqu'elle se
situe au carrefour de la méditerranée et
de l'asie et contrôlent donc pas mal de
routes commerciales zénobie épouse
septimus rodez nat en 256 il a déjà un
fils issu d'un premier mariage et ran et
un deuxième enfant né de leur union en
266 à cette époque l'an pierre romain va
mal il subit des invasions barbares sur
le rhin sur le danube et le longue
l'euphrate avec les perses les empereurs
romains se succèdent sans succès et très
peu meurent dans leur lit faute de
moyens elle se contente de défendre le
front danubien pour protéger l'italie et
les autres provinces doivent se démerder
par enel certaines régions se dote alors
d'un chef local comme la gaule par
exemple qui instaure une lignée
d'empereur pendant dix ans non pas par
volonté de sédition avec rome mais parce
qu'il ya urgence à se défendre vers 260
l'empereur valait rien confie la défense
de la région à eau des nattes et lui
demande de marché contre les perses ce
qu'il fait avec succès puisqu'il
remporte une première bataille contre en
261 à partir de là il se proclame grand
vainqueur des perses roi des rois bref
il prend le melon mais devient l'un des
hommes les plus célèbres de son époque
ces victoires font de lui le maître de
la syrie et de la mésopotamie toutes les
deux reprises aux perses et les cinq
légions romaines de la région se rallie
à lui tout va pour le mieux palmyre
retrouve sa sécurité et aux des nattes
défend l' empire poursuivant les pertes
jusqu'en mer noire c'est là bas
d'ailleurs qu'il est assassiné en 267
avec son fils par un proche qui
l'accusent de vouloir usurper le trône
impérial
rien ne prouve que c'était le cas au
tennesse n'a par exemple jamais frappé
de mener à son nom usurpé le trône
mettait donc soit pas son intention du
tout soit il n'en a pas eu le temps au
moment de son assassinat ou à bâle est
le fils de des nattes et de zénobie
l'étagé que d'un an zénobie hérite alors
de tout son royaume de son armée et des
fidèles de son mari elle prend le titre
de reine bien qu'il n'existe pas
vraiment d'empyr de palmyre et de mère
du roi des mois zénobie est un peu plus
ambitieuse que son mari d'abord durant
trois ans elle essaye d'imposer son fils
comme empereur d'orient en reconnaissant
que l' empereur d'occident conserverait
un rang supérieur ça va elle fait
qualifié la balade d'empereur sur des
bords des documents ce qui constitue
déjà un coup d'état mais continue de
qualifier l'empereur d'occident
d'auguste et non ce n'est pas un clown
si vous connaissez un peu l'histoire de
l'empiré romain vous savez peut-être
qu'ils se séparent effectivement deux en
285 soit 15 ans seulement après la
défaite de zénobie car spoiler elle va
perdre mais tout ça pour dire que la
division de lempire n'était ni une idée
sortie nulle part ni est réalisable il
était même déjà arrivé que lorient soit
confié temporairement à des hommes de
confiance en temps de crise bref son
royaume est reconnu par rome jusqu'à un
certain point zénobie tient sa cour à
palmyre ou elle s'entoure de les traits
de philosophes notamment callinicos qui
lui dédier un livre où il a comparé à
cléopâtre le classe en 270 justement
elle conquiert l'egypte et expulse le
préfet romain tena guinot probus elle le
fait ensuite exécuté lorsqu'ils tentent
de reprendre le territoire elle se
proclame alors reine d'égypte et impose
un chantage à rome puisqu'une grande
partie des ressources et des impôts de
l'empiré proviennent d'égypte à partir
de là elle frappe monnaie à son image et
à celle de son fils font d'une ville ce
qui est bien un truc de souverains et
parle sur ses actes publics du règne
commun de nos seniors aurélien et well
as tu auguste mais malgré tous ses
appels du pied aurélien ne répond
toujours pas à cette demande de partage
du coup elle décide de marcher sur rome
encore une fois à l'idée qu'une famille
provinciales puissent prendre le pouvoir
à rome n'est pas si folle en cette
époque troublée en plus tout peut
arriver
l' empire a déjà été dirigé par un et
bien d'origine phénicienne septime
sévère et par le bien nommé philippe
l'arabe 20 ans avant zénobie même
l'empereur actuelle aurélien était à la
base un militaire néo paysans dans la
région du danube niveau prestige on a vu
mieux l'armée de palmyre se met donc en
marche en passant par l'anatolie dans le
but d'atteindre rome et de réunifier
lempire au nom de son fils cependant
aurélien se met en marche de son côté
aussi avec arme et du danube et
rencontres l'armée de zénobie vers
ankara il la refoule vers antioche puis
et mèze assiègent palmyre et saccagent
la ville zénobie cherchent à fuir b à
aurélien par les perses aurélien profite
aussi de cette période pour reprendre le
pouvoir en gaule l'intégrité de l'empiré
restauré pour peu de temps certes on ne
sait pas comment meurt ou à bagdad
peut-être pendant le trajet vers rome
zénobie et emmenés en tant qu'otage et à
partir de là les versions divergent un
auteur dit qu'elle meurt de maladie ou
se laissent mourir sur le bateau un
autre raconte qu'elle est traîné dans le
cortège triomphal d'aurélien en 274
avant d'être exécutées comme
vercingétorix
un autre enfin plus fantaisistes prétend
qu'elle est gracié après le triomphe
d'aurélien impressionné par sa beauté il
aurait envoyé finir sa vie dans une
villa de tibur aujourd'hui tivoli où
elle aurait épousé un sénateur romain la
fille née de cette union aurait même
épousé l'empereur aurélien mais
puisqu'il meurt assassiné en 275 elle
aurait été mariées très jeunes voire
même avant sa conception au final rien
n'indique qu'elle version de l'histoire
et la vraie ce qui au 4e siècle se
prétendent encore descendants de zénobie
ont toutes les chances de se rattacher à
une ascendance glorieuse mais imaginaire
tout comme les no be le faisait avec léo
patry
après la chute de zénobie la ville de
pamiers redevient une simple forteresse
contre les perses et disparaît de la
grande histoire le règne de zénobie qui
tente de s'imposer face à l' empire
romain nous rappelle celui de body cas
dont j'avais parlé dans mon tout premier
gentes dames bad ass et je vous
reparlerai d'elle plus en profondeur un
jour d'ailleurs comme elle zénobie tente
d'asseoir sa légitimité face à un empire
parfois incompétents voir abusif mes
chevaux dans son entreprise zénobie est
célébrée en peinture à l'opéra et elle
devient même avec palmyre un prénom en
vogue au 19e siècle
voilà j'espère que cet épisode vous a
plu si vous voulez en savoir plus sur et
nos vies et sur palmyre je peux vous
recommander la lecture assez accessible
et agréable de palmira les paul veyne
écrit après la destruction de la ville
antique en 2015 et je citerai aussi
d'autres sources dans la description si
vous voulez aller plus loin si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo vous pouvez dire wapala
tu auguste en commentaire pour montrer
votre soutien à zénobie ça lui fera très
plaisir
le croit désolé aussi pour le longtemps
entre les deux épisodes la chaîne a été
à l'arrêt pendant quelques mois parce
que j'étais en pleine pré-production de
la saison de marc webb série time warp
et c'était génial le tournage s'est
déroulé fin juillet début août et ça
s'est super bien passé on a de beaux
plans de beau jeu et donc j'ai très hâte
que vous voyez le résultat en 2022 du
coup en attendant si vous n'avez jamais
vu la saison une de taille noir que vous
pouvez toujours la regarder en c'est
l'occasion elle se trouve sur ma chaîne
sur une playlist dédié vous les
retrouverez très facilement merci aussi
d'être toujours présent et donc je me
retrouve à très bientôt pour chroniques
de profs à 6
[Musique]